[inaudible].
Hi everybody.
I guess my job is to ask
you how you're feeling. Um,
you think I'm kidding.
I have to just say before I start
that I did not create the title for my
presentation.
I have to put the onus there and Danielle,
I would probably get fired from this
presentation title. I'm just kidding.
Um,
so I want to start off with a quote
can ask everyone to get some like
maybe good posture in your seats,
some of your like,
take a nice inhale,
maybe just get settled and just think
about how this quote resonates with you.
And I'll just read it.
No one cares how much you know
until they know how much you care.
What do we think?
Okay.
Does that resonate with you at all or
are you thinking, well, I'm pretty smart,
right?
My students at Y'all say that a lot.
Like what do you mean nobody
cares how much, you know, I
know everything. I'm like,
well, maybe about some things, probably
not about how to interact very well. But,
um,
and you know,
my work is primarily in education.
So I work with school systems to help
bring the principles of emotional
intelligence into what I call the immune
system of the way the school operates,
from how leaders lead
to how teachers teach,
to how students learn
to help parents parent.
And what I've learned over the years is
that this quote really is the truth for
the way education works.
As a 47 year old
psychologist, professor, um,
I went back to the middle school
that I attended about five years ago,
after 33 years ago, a bullying. Uh,
it was a pretty horrifically bullied kid.
And, um, when I went back to my school,
I had no memories of anything I learned.
I had no memories of, of my
even many of my peers. Uh,
I couldn't remember any teachers name,
but I remember how I felt walking in that
hallway, like the terror and the fear.
Um, and I remember thinking, why didn't
anybody ever asked me how I felt?
Why didn't anyone ever
attend to my feelings? Um,
hence now I spend my whole
life running around the world,
getting everybody to talk
about their feelings. Um,
so one tool that we developed to help
people become aware of feelings just to
the basic level is called the mood meter.
So I'm going to teach you a
little bit about this right now.
All of you got some email or whatever.
Notice you got here at Google about a
presentation on emotional intelligence and
you're here now, which is wonderful. Um,
so my question for you is how are you
feeling right now not about life minus
five would be you're having
thoughts, something like, really,
I have to listen to this guy for a whole
hour. Like that's, that's what we do now.
Google, we have people come talk
about feelings. Maybe you're there,
maybe you're at minus
three and pleasantness.
You're having thoughts or something like,
yeah,
whatever
maybe or neutral.
I live in Connecticut now. I feel like
that's the state of our entire state,
right? We're like the neutral
state. Um, not a lot of emotion.
Maybe you're a plus three. You're
thinking to yourself, my goodness,
I get to sit in a room with a guy from
Connecticut that who's going to talk
about feelings, uh, are
maybe or a plus five.
Like there are no words in the
English language dictionary,
right to describe the feeling
you're having right now.
So please give yourself a number from
minus five to plus five in terms of your
current level of pleasantness.
And the y axis is his energy.
So energy has to do literally with
how much activation you have going on,
plus five [inaudible].
You're so activated, you
just can't contain yourself.
Minus five is you're in your
deepest pool of despair.
Minus five. Do you feel like you're
being pulled into the ground?
Plus five is you are just so highly
energized. You can't contain your body.
Where's your energy right now?
Obviously we create our mood meter from
these two axes. So we've got yellow, red,
blue, and green. Let me
just see where you are.
How many of you are feeling yellow
right now? High Energy and pleasant.
Okay, that's impressive. Um, how many
of you are green? You're a pleasant,
but your energy's kind of low.
How many of you are in
the blue or red today?
Okay,
the three people sitting in the back row.
Okay, Alicia got good distance from me.
That's good. Um, now the question is,
are we being authentic
and honest right now?
Is it true that 85 to 90% of the room
is actually feeling quote unquote yellow
and green? Highly doubtful. I mean
maybe life here. Is that amazing?
I live in Connecticut or the East Coast
is not known for its yellow and green
feelings.
Um,
what I want you to do right now is take
about three seconds and convert your
quadrant to a word.
Take three seconds please.
What is the word that best
describes your current feeling?
All right. Freeze. Gimme
an honest raise of hands.
How many of you had some trouble
finding the precise word?
Hands up high. Like really high?
Please look around the room. Everybody.
Okay,
so it's interesting.
I mean at least it is Timmy.
Here we are our room filled with highly
educated people who are emotionally
illiterate. Okay. Now I'd be like,
I don't like this guy already. I
want to ask you for, take a second.
What are your hypotheses around that? What
do you think? Why would it be, I mean,
truthfully,
you're all highly educated people.
Why would you not be able to find a word
to describe how you're failing? Yes.
There's many feelings happening
at the same time. Like how many?
Like 14.
Okay.
Well we have treatment for that.
Alright. You're right
though. You could have,
you feel you may be filling more than
one emotion. 14 is a lot, but I'll, I'll,
yeah.
I think that the way that our success
is structure rewards us for divorcing,
um, intelligence and
strategy from our emotions.
Okay. So like we're in a society that
just has like put the feelings aside.
So maybe you haven't developed your
vocabulary for it because you're having
attended to it.
Any other hypotheses?
Yeah,
it's a natural resistance to collapsing
the complexity of your internal state.
We'll color.
Uh Huh.
So there's this repeat that please.
Natural resistance to collapsing
the complexity to what?
All right.
So maybe it's like we're just way too
dynamic to put ourselves into one quadrant
or one feeling word. Very
point. Yeah. Last one.
Yup.
Yup. So maybe around how your focus,
what your, where your focus is, right?
If I asked you how you feeling in life,
that's a very big question.
If I ask you how you're
feeling about attending a talk
on emotional intelligence,
it might help you be more precise
potentially. Now. All right.
All of you are here for an hour.
That's the time of the presentation.
How many of you will have some trouble
staying focused for a whole hour?
Raise your hand. Okay, wonderful. Great.
I have a room filled with
attention deficit disorder. Um,
just what I hope for in life.
Um,
so I'm going to give
you an ideal spot to be.
I would like you to be around plus
one plus one for my presentation.
I'm going to set an emotion goal for you.
I'm going to call that
the spot of joyful effort.
And what I'd like you to do is think
about where you are in reference to that
point and what strategy my best serve
you to kind of stay there for the next 45
minutes.
What strategy will best serve you?
Who feels they have a
an effective strategy?
No one. I'll be back.
Yeah, just being relaxed.
Just being relaxed.
Challenging things.
That speaker says,
I want the critical person in the road.
Like I don't like what I just said.
I want to argue that one. Yeah. Let
me,
if you can see how it
helps you a lot in life even
becoming just to the old state.
So I'll make it relevant to your life.
She goes to the opposite of his,
which was being receptive.
Thank you. Thank you. Take
it outside. Yeah. All right,
so one is going to be more critical.
You're going to be open,
you're going to be relaxed to, you are
going to make it relevant to your life.
You're going to just focus.
Yeah. Keeping it. Yes sir.
To be be present.
Yeah. They want to be present. All right.
So let's take this into the real world
because this is definitely not the real
world. And let's imagine
now I am what I do a lot.
I go into Middle School here in
Palo Alto and I walk in and say,
when everybody, my name is mark, I'm going
to be your teacher today and I know, uh,
your teacher loved me,
the script,
we're going to be doing their
Roman oligarchy today. Okay?
So what I want you to do,
I know that my goal is for you to be
in that kind of low yellow. And here's,
I'm going to just offer you some
strategies, just, just chill.
Just relax and be here,
okay?
I need you to make this relevant
to your life. If that doesn't work,
just be open.
And what I really want you to
do is it's just focus, right?
There is no past.
We know the future is like whatever.
So just be here with me now.
Be here in the present moment.
All right? Ready to go? What do you think?
How effective are those strategies?
So I want you to just take
a moment and think about it.
Well those strategies work.
How many of you ever asked
someone to calm down?
All right.
And how many of you in the hyster asking
someone to calm down and have found
that it really works, right? Like
with your partner? Like honey,
I love you but like I just need
you to calm down. All right,
what? I want to make someone mad.
That's what I say. Say. There you go.
So telling us that one
to strategize is complex.
Anything else that you see wrong with
those strategies or potentially right?
Yeah.
Well you're putting the onus of us
being attentive on us and not one,
both of us.
Oh good point.
You actually bring up a really good point,
which is that emotions are not
necessarily always self regulated, right?
That we are in relationship
and they are co-regulating
think about that,
right?
Whether it's a device that you're in
the room with or whether it's a human
being,
right?
You're in a co-regulation process because
how I present the facial expressions,
body language, vocal tones, the way
I present myself will influence.
And be contagious.
I many ways to your feelings,
which will then in turn come back to me.
So we're in this dynamic
reciprocal relationship right now,
whether we're conscious of it or not.
So as your teacher right now,
I am influencing how you're feeling,
which is a form of self regulation
or co-regulation. Other points.
Yeah. So you're getting
to the specificity, right?
You can't just say be present or be
focused or become like what do you do to
become,
what do you do to be present?
Everyone here just said that they're
going to have attention problems.
So what is the actual mental
strategy that you're engaging in?
To manage the feeling or
to create the feeling.
Okay.
Alright, everyone, sit up straight
in your seats for a moment. Please
take a nice long inhale and I exhale.
And if you're comfortable, close
your eyes. If not, not a problem.
It's five o'clock in the morning,
you're probably waste leap.
It's six maybe or seven o'clock in the
morning. You wake up. How do you feel?
This is internal talk right now as
you wake up each morning, typical day,
how do you feel?
Okay.
It's breakfast time.
Are you eating breakfast at home or are
you waiting to get to work or you're
having a good cup of coffee?
A bad cup of coffee.
How do you feel when you do
your morning routine? All right.
You're on your way to work. Traffic.
No traffic, public transportation.
How do you feel?
Okay.
What are you doing on your way to work?
Texting like you shouldn't be phone calls.
Radio.
All right. You arrive at
work, you walk around.
How do you feel meeting one,
meeting two meaning three mini four
meaning five meaning six meetings, seven,
28 million, 9 million. 10. Take
yourself through those meetings. Emails,
no emails. Phone calls, no phone calls.
The text, no texts. How do you feel?
Lunchtime. Healthy.
Unhealthy, relaxed. Stressful.
I use chewing. Or are you just
swallowing? How do you feel at lunch?
Who are you with?
Are you alone or with others?
Is it enjoyable or are you under pressure?
Okay,
it's after lunch. More meetings, more
emails, more meetings, more emails,
distractions. How are you feeling
in the afternoon? All right,
you're leaving work. What time
is it and where are you going?
Exercise. No exercise. Oh,
no. Time for exercise. Kids.
No kids, partner, no partner. Family,
no family with the afternoon like,
and how are you feeling?
Are you get home? Who is there?
Are you alone or with other people?
What's your evening like? You're watching
America's got talent or not reading,
not reading.
What's your evening like and how are
you feeling most evenings? All right,
it's time to go to bed.
What's your evening routine like?
What are you thinking about
as you put yourself to sleep?
Raise your hand if you think you had a
couple hundred emotions throughout the
day.
We should all raise your hand because you
probably had a couple of thousand. Uh,
we tend to experience around three
to five emotions in a minute in some
instances. Um, how many of you saw us?
But I won't ask you to raise your hands,
but if I were to ask you to kind of
plot yourself back on that mood meter,
do you see yourself kind of living in
one quadrant more throughout the day?
Do you see yourself going
throughout different quadrants?
Like yellow in the morning
and then blow it the meeting.
And then red here and then
green here and then yellow here.
So I've been really interested as a
researcher as to what are or what is the
emotional life of our nation.
And I've done three large studies
over the last couple of years. Uh,
the first one was a study with 45,000
high school students across the nation.
And this isn't collaboration,
uh, with the pop singer,
Lady Gaga and her
foundation born this way,
foundation and what we did a with
funding from the Robert Wood Johnson
Foundation,
we coin across United States and we
looked at the state of emotional fair.
So I asked you to think
about your feelings first.
Now let's think about our nation's youth
top three feelings that you believe our
nation's high school is public,
private and charter are feeling.
What do you think?
Confused. Stressed. Fear.
Insecure. Depressed. If I'm
going to ask you to think about,
look at it.
We got one optimist in the room.
If you were to take the whole pie of 100%
what percent are positive and emotions
is what percent of negative emotions?
What do you think?
Nine,
two thirds negative. All right,
well here are the results.
By 75% were negative.
Top three feelings.
We're tired, board and stressed
and went a little deeper.
And what we did was we
looked at all right,
what percentage of the time are these
kids experiencing these emotions?
We found that they say they're
stressed 80% of the time stressed, uh,
80% of the time board 70% of the time.
So I want you to think about like what's
happening if you want to think about
innovation and creativity,
right?
What happens if you're in an
environment where you're feeling tired,
board and stressed, Hungover,
Warren's drafts, tired, worn, rest,
high board and stressed.
Now as a professor at a
pretty prestigious place,
I was curious like what's the state
of emotional affairs of the brightest
crayons in the box?
So I did a study last year with undergrads
and here is the state of affairs at
Yale. It looks a little
similar, doesn't it?
Stress, number one, overwhelmed, anxious,
frustrated. There some excitement,
uh, which is good, but about 70% of
the emotions they're experiencing.
And then I went and I said,
I'm really interested in teachers,
which is my primary area.
I said,
what does the state of of
affairs of America's educators,
frustrated, stressed, overwhelmed,
some happiness and joyful.
But if you look at the,
all the little words,
most of them are not
the most pleasant words.
And then with funding
from another foundation,
I decided to look at 25,000 people
across the entire workforce.
And here's what people across
the United States feel. I work.
Stress is the number one
feeling. Some other ones too,
a little bit of motivation,
busy, tired, engaged. And
what we know from our work,
right is that there's the
good stress and bad stress.
I actually like to hire people
who experience some stress.
I like people have slight anxiety
problems or they get stuck,
they get stuff done.
Um, that's good stress.
Unfortunately, when we do the more
detailed analysis of what's happening,
we find that it's most of the bad
stress that people are feeling.
The stress that makes them
not want to go to work.
This stress that makes him not really
be present at work, that's just,
that makes them feel physically sick.
Now,
for most of my career,
I've been fighting people in
terms of caring about emotions.
Just for your, uh, my own curiosity
for people here at Google.
How many of you believe that
these feelings that you just saw
from tired board and stressed to stressed,
overwhelmed and anxious to frustrated,
stressed and overwhelmed,
distressed matter
and matter for important
things about a person's life?
So what I've learned in my research is
that emotions matter for five big reasons.
The first of the attention,
memory learning.
So how you're feeling right now in my
presentation is driving your presence,
your focus, your engagement,
your critical analysis.
If you're a board,
you're already somewhere else.
You're already working on your project.
If you're frustrated,
you're back there thinking, oh my God,
what am I going to do? If you're stressed,
you're thinking, how do we get
out of here? So I think back now,
33 years ago when I was in middle
school and being bullied. And why?
I have no memory of anything that
I learned. It was because why?
Because my brain with
preoccupied with survival, right?
My brain was preoccupied with friendships,
the need for friendships.
So why would I want to be in a classroom?
Why would I even care about learning
about the Roman oligarchy when I'm afraid
to walk home or when I'm not
having positive relationships?
The second is decision making.
I'm just curious if any of
you ever made a bad decision.
Anyone like to just share publicly right
now to just let it out so we know that
how we feel shifts the way we
make choices and decisions.
I'll give you one example.
So in my work with schools,
I did a random experiment
where I took educators.
Let's imagine you're all teachers and I
just randomly assign you think about a
day. That was great. Think about a day
that was shitty. Great Day, Shitty Day,
great day, Shitty Day. It's been
five minutes just writing about it.
And then immediately thereafter I gave
every single educator in that study the
same essay to read.
Does anyone think there were differences
in the grades? They assigned,
there was a one to two full grade
difference and the way the teachers on a
greater these students,
right?
Just five minute little essay or writing
assignment about good day, bad day,
and then they graded the paper and there
were one to two full grade on average
difference.
I kind of knew it was going to happen
cause I know how emotions influence
thinking. I think what interested me
most was at the end of the study I said,
do you believe that how you felt
influence the way you evaluated the essay?
What percentage of the educators
do you said, yeah, of course.
Right about 90% denied it.
They said there's no way that how I
felt what an influence the way evaluated
that essay.
And I think what that tells us is a lot.
I think the primary thing is that our
emotions are influencing and biasing the
way we're seeing the world and
the choices that we're making,
but it's happening outside
of our conscious awareness.
The third is relationship quality.
Just curious,
does anyone here have a colleague did
not look to your left or your right?
Uh, or a relative who displays
a lot of negative emotion.
Someone who maybe walks around like this,
does anybody know something like that?
Or they're very disagreeable.
I don't like that idea. Why you want
to do it that way? Um, where I work,
I get things like this perfect bracket.
I've got a question.
I'm not really sure you know
the answer. Okay? Not a problem.
A lot of problem.
Can't wait to grade your freaking paper.
And so we know that emotions are signals
and they tell us to approach our to avoid.
So when we think about people and
we think about products, right?
How they make us feel makes want
to move toward them or against,
does that resonate with everyone?
So that,
and that's a basic thing around survival,
right?
We don't approach the angering expression
because we got to protect ourselves
from it. We don't want to approach
people who make us feel bored, right?
Because we know we're just not going to
want to be in relationship with them.
People who display more positive
emotions or who are more gentle in their
expressions, right? They're
saying, I'm here for you. Right?
If I walk around like
this and I might talk
right? Immediately you're thinking, oh,
this guy's not approachable. You know,
I'm not. You've got power
issues. He's got control issues.
The fourth is physical and mental health.
So it's interesting.
I was in a meeting last week,
two weeks ago now I'm with a group of
the counselors from universities around
the state of Connecticut.
And what the research now shows
is that for the last five years,
there has been a 20% increase in
psychiatric hospitalizations for
undergraduates.
So it's kind of 20% a year for the
last five years with the research.
My own shows is that if we took the
indicators of stress for adolescents and
teenagers in our nation,
they are greater than the stress levels
of the adults who are raising them.
So you can imagine what's going on in
our nation right now when everyone is
having this high activation emotion,
right? Cortisol being released,
confusion happening, and ability to
concentrate. Lots of other things.
The final piece is on
creativity. Now, Google is not
really known for that, right?
Um, how many of you believe
that creativity is important?
Good. Um, that's good news. Um,
one thing interesting that we have found
is that in our studies of young adults
that how they feel and their emotion
skills is highly correlated with their
ability to be creative.
Well,
we know from research is that cognitive
ability correlates with creativity but
only up to an average Iq level.
So most people think that creativity
is a cognitive process, right?
That the more high, the higher your
Iq is, the more creative you are.
What happens with cognitive
abilities that it does this.
So the question is what's explaining
the rest of the variance in creativity?
And what we're finding is that
it has to be emotion skills.
Any hypotheses of why
that might be the case?
Why would it emotion skills be responsible
for the creative process and product?
Great Point. So if you're
under pressure, pressure,
pressure all the time and your kind of
default network is never able to kind of
be activated, right? How can
you be creative? What else?
Awareness of how the thing that you're
creating is affecting you or you and the
people who are going to buy it.
So putting emotion into the product as
well as imagining what the feelings are,
the recipient of that product.
What else you're afraid of failing.
You probably not going to go very
far. It's a great point. Now,
how many of you've heard of
this concept called grit? Yup.
So what we find in our research is that
grit is not correlated with creativity
or academic achievement, but that
the skills of emotion management are,
and I think the reason for that
is that has anyone here ever,
how many of you have actually attempted
to be creative and have failed that an
attempt? Yeah. Um,
how many of you have ever
gotten negative feedback?
How many of you ever been frustrated
with your own design of something?
Have you ever been
disappointed in your own work?
So emotions are inherent
in everything we do.
And some people, they, boy, you
just got to plow through it,
but not really the case,
right?
The more the wider base
our strategies are,
the more effective we're going to be.
So how do you manage the disappointment?
How do you manage the frustration?
How do you manage being overwhelmed?
How do you manage the feedback? I
mean, I get feedback all the time.
I was doing this presentation in New York
recently as given one guy looks at me,
he's like, you know, I know
like this stuff. And I was
like, well, I don't like you.
So like not a problem.
We don't have to work together.
I gave a talk recently at
my own university to the
surgeons in one department
and right after my presentation was over
to sergeant stands up and I'm waiting
for him to like compliment
me and he's like,
what has happened to
Yale? I was like, wow,
like that's, I was like, okay, keep
going. And then he goes, this is,
yeah,
we're about producing Nobel laureates,
not nice people.
I was like,
you've got to be kidding me.
And then I said,
does anybody else feel any different?
Of course it got worse as the other guy,
he raised his hand, he goes,
I've learned in my work.
Sometimes you gotta be an asshole.
Then people just shut up and
do what you tell them to do.
And I looked over at the chair of the,
this big department. I'm like, I might,
it's just like a movie being made
right now. Like where the hell am I?
So in life when we're
trying to be creative,
we're trying to do the things
that we think are important.
There's going to be a million people
that are going to get in the way. Um,
you know,
and the question is,
do we have the strategies to persevere
and do we have the strategies to manage
the difficult emotions that come up for
us as we're trying to create something.
So that leads us to this whole model
of like, what do you do about it?
And what I've learned is that if you want
to do great work in terms of this idea
of emotional intelligence,
first we've got to get people on the bus.
Like,
do you believe that emotions matter?
And I'm not sure we're in a nation that
believes that how people feel matters.
I think that we're a couple of
hundred years behind unfortunately.
And you see that all the time. Like I
had a student last semester because like,
so now you're asking me to put,
plop myself on your mood meter.
On my to do list. I'm like, yeah,
actually if you want to take my class,
guess what?
You're going to be checking in with
your feelings pretty regularly.
And there's so much resistance to this
idea of like infusion of emotion, right?
So step one I think is mindset.
What I've learned also is that
if you're trying to do good work,
you really can't just train one person
or in schools like the third grade
teacher is going to do this in their
classroom. It doesn't make any sense.
It's got to be infused into the system
so that it changes the DNA in many ways.
But it's not just about the skills, it's
about the climate. So you can put the,
you know, someone with skills
into a toxic environment,
but then they have no opportunity to
express those skills. So in my research,
what we're finding is that when you
simultaneously focus on the skill building
and also creating a more healthy
emotional climate, you get great outcomes.
All right? So that means we've
got to first develop the skills
are they get to take a moment and
think of someone who you know,
who is emotionally wise
that anyone know someone who you would
say is like the personification of
emotional intelligence.
What are those skills?
What do you think? Just let's
hear real quickly, what are,
what do you think are the skills of the
emotionally intelligent person? Yeah,
they're a good listener. All
right. What else? Attentive.
Empathy. Curious, calm.
There was no experience. Personal
experience, state control,
state control, time. Further response,
sense of humor.
Said again,
equanimity,
suspending judgment,
not impulsive.
Anything else come up.
Then a stand themselves.
So can we get more granular than that?
He really,
what are the skills,
the underlying abilities of the emotion
and Delta was it'd be a good listener to
being good and to be empathic, right?
Those are in many ways outcomes.
What are the underlying
skills? Well, because of the
time, I'll just tell you them.
So we call those skills
emotional intelligence and
there are five basic skills.
The first is recognizing emotion.
A second is understanding.
The third is labeling. That fourth is
expressing and the fifth is regulating.
So let's jump through them. Thank
you. Which is the name of my model.
This guy's good.
Recognizing emotion,
so we understand emotion through
identifying thoughts and feelings through
paying attention to other people's facial
expressions, body language, vocal tone.
Now it's interesting.
Not all emotion concepts
are emotions per se.
So let's try the vocal tone one. That's
a nice one. I had a stressful time,
just so you know, getting here for, I
was in Mexico doing your presentation.
It was a little frustrating. Getting
here could use a little compassion.
So I like to see if Googlers can generate
the sound of compassion on the count
of one, three, two, one.
I don't think that was universal. Just
say that was like four of you. All right,
let's try it again. On the count of one,
the side of compassion. Three, two, one.
Hi. That was pretty good, right?
All right, now let's here.
Let's say you're like, I can't
stand this guy. I am disgusted.
And the count of one
discussed three, two, one.
Now you're like, oh my goodness. This is
like, I've never seen anything like this.
You are in awe. Three, two,
one. That's pretty good.
Now you are feeling deep love for me.
Like just the love that you just,
there are no words for your
love on the count of one.
The sound of love. Three, two, one.
All right,
so that was different.
Was it that you were able to have pretty
good tone for compassion and awe and
discuss,
but love was a little off.
You don't feel it that off. All
right, well we'll work on that.
Anyone else? What do you think? I'm sorry.
It's a more complex emotion.
It's a private emotion.
So there are private and public
emotions you think? All right.
Well some of the other ones you
mentioned were more instantaneous,
so there's a direct reaction concern,
but love is not an immediate reaction
to the last thing you said. It's,
it has duration time.
So the question, yeah,
let's try another one.
Let's imagine that you're looking at me
like I want this guy to come live with
me. You are feeling desire, like
you've never felt that before before.
On the count of one, the sound
of desire? Three, two, one.
All right, well at least it
makes me feel a little better.
It's the only way I get it nowadays,
right? I got to like ask for it. Um,
that was maybe too much
information. But anyway, the,
so love maybe is more of a feeling,
not an emotion,
whereas surprise is an automatic response
to a stimulus that causes a shift in
our behavior and our physiology and our
cognition where love is more complex.
It's more of a feeling.
But desire is more like an emotion
because there's an automatic response to a
stimulus. So it helps us get
this language for emotion, right?
Is it a mood? Is it a
feeling, is an emotion?
And we want to recognize all of the above.
The second is understanding of motion.
Why am I having these feelings?
Where are they coming from?
How is what I'm feeling influencing my
thinking, my judgments and behavior?
So here's an easy one for all of you.
I'm going to ask you to
differentiate to emotions.
How many of you've heard of the
word anger and disappointment?
Good.
I want to know from you.
You've got 30 seconds.
Make it 20 now to differentiate the two,
what is the actual difference and what
makes someone feel angry as opposed to
disappointment? Who feels they've
got it? We have one confident person.
All right, I'm going to go with you
in the back. What does that mean?
Okay,
so you're talking about the energy factor.
I want to further push that to say
what's the underlying difference in the
causal pieces of it?
What makes you go to anger
versus disappointment?
How about you?
Okay,
back there
and anger.
Okay.
You just get any of it.
Everything I can get anywhere
at the drop of anything. Yes.
Anger as a physiological response.
Wash of adrenaline. All right.
Uh, I've called a nearby I
once, someone over there,
what do we think?
Let's stop the presentation now.
How many of you are walking out of
here thinking, I got the difference?
It's interesting, isn't it? Like these
are two words that we use all the time,
but yet when we try to get to
the granularity of understanding,
there are differences.
It becomes more complex.
So disappointment has to do
with unmet expectations, right?
I thought it was going to work this way.
I thought I was going to get the AA.
I just, everything was legit though
and I just didn't, didn't make it.
Anger tends to have a theme of
injustice or unfairness. Right?
That was not fair. How could
you say, how could you do that?
How many of you believe that there are
people who are feeling disappointment but
expressing it in a way
that looks like anger?
What do you think happens all the time.
I was one of those kids,
so I went to karate to become like
this tough guy. As you can see,
it worked really well.
And um, I came home and I,
cause I failed my yellow belt test.
I was like devastated.
I mean it was like really not in a good
place. Come home. I look at my car,
I hate you. How could you
maybe go to karate? I hate you.
I'm never going to karate. I'm not
even going to call tomorrow. Uh,
and my parents did what they
knew how to do. My mother says,
you can't talk to me that way. Go to your
room, wait till your father gets home.
Great father gets home.
I thought I told you never to
talk to your mother that way.
You know mark for crying out loud.
I've had it right.
Not once did anyone say
so like what happened?
Like how you feeling sad and so I got
punished for being aggressive but no one
actually knew how I was feeling now.
It could have been like it
looked like I was angry.
It could have been one of a million
stories. One I didn't just do,
I just didn't do all the test
too is the bull. He said to me,
we knew where you're
going to pass the test.
We're going to get you tomorrow
morning on the way to school.
I mean a million things could
be underneath the behavior
and what happens in our
world is that we work or we spend way
too much time judging behavior and
attributing emotions to the behavior as
opposed to really understanding what the
feeling and emotion is,
which is why we need vocabulary.
We say we have to name it to tame
it because if I'm disappointed,
how you support me will be very
different than if I'm angry.
Which leads to our rules
around expressing emotion,
the context,
is it appropriate,
is it inappropriate and
many things influence that.
Your personality influences it,
your cultural background,
your race, your agenda,
your own upbringing.
So I have two older brothers who are
great guys and they don't really know what
to do. They're 11 and eight
years older than I am,
so by the time I was like seven or
eight they were out of the house.
We have close friends now,
but they convinced that basically what
mark does is he makes money by thinking
in coffee shops and I was like,
I actually have a real career guys.
Like I write papers I teach. So
I said, come on to hear me speak.
And they came to New York to one of
my presentations. First 15 minutes.
It was like really cool. Like my two
older brothers they were looking at,
that's my brother.
About 20 minutes in.
All of a sudden I see my one
brother looking at by the religious,
like really not in a good place.
And I realized afterwards that it was at
the point where I was saying I've been
bullied.
It was up to the point I was talking
about my neurotic mother and my angry
father and my two brothers.
And so at the end of my talk, I want
us to my brother, I'm like, so guys,
we have my brother's. He was
like, really pass. He's like,
don't even walk out with me. I'm
like, are you serious? He's like,
you share way too much. You're
too vulnerable. I'm like, Dave,
like I'm the director of the
center emotional intelligence.
Like if I can't talk about my feelings,
no one's going to tell you about their
failings. And he's like, and I, you know,
and, and he went on and on. Then the
last thing he said was something like,
and you know what?
Okay,
people are going to see you as being weak.
Which is fascinating to me that because
I share so much about being a victim of
bullying and how I had all
these challenges growing
up and my parents were this
way that that was going to make
people see me as weak. Right?
I remember looking at my one brother,
I'm like, Dave, like I don't know.
In my department we call that
projection, right? Like I'm doing okay.
Just let you know I'm doing
all right. Um, but it shows me,
right that we all have our rules.
Okay,
don't we? We have rules about emotion. Do
I talk about them too? I talk about them.
Am I a hugger? I'm not a hugger.
Do I give good eye contact?
Am I not give eye contact?
Is it cultural cause it is cultural.
There's no doubt about it.
That was a cultural,
which leads us to the last
skill of emotional intelligence,
which is the big one,
which is emotion regulation,
right?
What are the strategies that I have
available to me to manage it all?
Emotions to not just downregulate
the negative ones, but the upgrade,
like the ones that I need to
achieve a goal. So, for example,
if you were here and you said,
well,
I'm in the blue when I asked
you to be in the yellow,
what's your strategy for
shifting into that place? Yeah,
that's an upregulating strategy.
Most people's conceptions of emotion
regulation is that it's regulating down.
What we're saying is that it's
about preventing unwanted emotions,
reducing difficult emotions,
initiating ones that you want to have,
maintaining emotions
that are useful to you,
that you're experiencing and even
boosting or enhancing emotions.
And it's interesting, like
right now, if I'm stressed out,
like let's say I'm looking at your
facial expressions and watching Danielle
because she's like my boss here and
I'm thinking of myself, all right,
is it going well? What do you think?
You know, I dunno. Uh, she looked down,
oh my God. And she looked over at
her boss and she went like, Oh shit.
Like it's never gonna work out. I can't
be like, Ugh, I've got to do yoga. Right?
I can just start doing yoga right now
to deal with my stress levels. I mean,
I could, but like, it's not
going to work very well.
So I met, I could do it and
I just did a little demo, but
I can't really do yoga in
the moment to regulate.
I've got to have cognitive strategies.
Does that resonate with you?
So different environments call for the Di,
a different type of strategizing.
And what I've learned in the last 20
years of running around talking about this
stuff is that most people,
if I say to them,
what's your go to strategy when you're
feeling this way to help you manage it?
What are you talking about? They
don't really have the language for it,
nor do they have the tool bag
with those strategies in it.
And it's kind of my goal is to make
sure that everybody has that tool bag.
Because I know what it's like
to not have the tool bag.
Has anyone here ever
experienced a strong emotion?
Has anyone here have experienced strong
emotion that didn't regulate very
effectively?
And how many of you just want to live
in that space for the rest of your life?
Right. It's not a great
place to live in. Right?
So I feel like it's my duty to make
sure we teach these things now.
Oh my goodness.
And then there's time left.
So before we wrap up in
the next three hours,
I've all, I've talked to the five
skills, recognize, understand, label,
express and regulate. Um,
now you know what they are.
I'm going to ask you to think how
emotionally intelligent are you on a scale
from one to five. One, you are
emotionally bankrupt. You don't have,
you can't read a person from
like right in front of you.
You have no strategies to regulate
to five, you are really skilled.
Where would you say you are?
How many of you give yourselves a one?
Like you are just
emotionally like not skilled.
We've got one semi honest person too.
Three,
four,
five. Okay. It's interesting.
I would say the average
and it was around 3.75.
Um,
how do you know?
Yeah,
I was like,
I dunno how I know.
How many of you have got an accurate
feedback on your emotion perception.
Ability.
Okay.
Or your emotion regulation skills.
Yeah.
And how do you know that it was accurate?
The feedback.
What's that
depends on her emotional intelligence,
right? Think about it like who's giving
you the feedback, right? Like my,
what's that? Yeah, that might be the case.
Although I've had about seven therapists
in my life. Um, so it's tricky,
right? This idea of self
awareness around emotion skills.
What my research shows by the way,
is that the correlation coefficient
between yourself rated emotional
intelligence and your actual
emotional skills is about zero.
So self ratings don't go very far in
this domain because it really is about a
skill and a mental ability.
It's like asking someone how smart they
think they are or asking parents or rate
how smart their kids on it.
Now,
what I want to wrap up with for just
a few minutes of sharing you what we
actually do.
So we know from our research that when
we measure emotional intelligence as a
set of skills, it looks
pretty good. Less skilled.
Kids look like this,
high skilled kids look like that.
We know that when we work
with managers and leaders,
more skills look pretty good.
People like to be around
people that have these skills.
I just did this huge study with
supervisors, emotional intelligence.
So think about this same amount of work,
right?
If you have a supervisor who is low
in emotional intelligence are high in
emotional intelligence,
you're working the same.
This side's a little complex.
But think about how you feel at work.
If your supervisor is low
and emotional intelligence,
you're feeling inspiration 28%
of the time if they're high,
80%.
So how you feel about your work and how
you feel at work tends to correlate very
highly with the emotional
skills of your supervisor.
Look at that.
Feelings of burnout at work,
almost triple fear of speaking up.
So people are afraid to speak up and to
even have an opinion when they have a
supervisor who's low in emotional
intelligence, engagement, triple
finding purpose and meaning at your work.
So what we find is that
these skills really play out
in meaningful and important
ways in everyday life.
The last thing I'll share with you
is what do we do to develop them?
So you've got nature,
not nurture.
So nature are things like your
temperament and personality.
Are any of you like me? Like people who
worry more than you'd like to worry? Yeah,
I have that.
I was like born with the worry Jean.
I even now I live in worry about
why worry anybody else like that.
And I'm at a point now in my
career like I worry about why,
worry about why worry and I like
mark like you're doing fine.
You don't think they worry about, but then
it's like, oh, something will go wrong.
So that's my genetics. 10 Years of
therapy, 25 years as a psychologist,
16 curriculum on emotional
intelligence and I,
my default is who worry.
Um,
nothing has changed my automatic worry,
which has been frustrating. I was like,
so I've learned that that is my
temperament, right? That's my personality.
What I need or strategies on how to learn,
how to live better with who I am.
I can't change my genetics,
but I can change the way I,
those feelings and how I
regulate them in everyday life.
And that's where the
nurture piece comes in.
It also is influenced by your
own development. So guess what?
I grew up with a mom who would
say things that had smoked. Honey,
you're being bullied. Don't tell me
the details. I'll have a breakdown.
Like Ma, like I'm having a breakdown.
It's like you're my mother.
You're supposed to have the strategies.
So,
and I had a father who was a tough guy
from the Bronx who son get in there.
All right dad, that sounds like, yeah,
I'm just going to get in there like
it's not going. I'll never be the,
I have a fifth degree black belt now.
I really do.
I mean I could eliminate anyone in this
room, but like it's not in my genetics.
I don't like to fight. I like the
techniques. I think the movements,
I don't want to hurt anybody.
Want to touch anybody.
So that led me to work for the last 20
years on an approach to teaching these
skills. And I'll just spend
very little time on that today.
And then hopefully we can get into
more detail with some of the teams.
We developed tools,
we learned that you have to be in an
environment where emotions matter,
not where rules role. So we said, why
don't we ask people how they want to feel.
The second is a tool to build self
awareness and vocabulary and strategies.
We also realized that a lot of people
have difficulty with triggers like certain
people and certain circumstances that
really activates strong emotions.
So we developed a tool
called the Meta moment.
Then we realized that we're
too self focused, right?
We'll live in a world where when conflict
arises, it's between and among people.
So let's think about that. This is a
great principal of a school named dawn.
This is her emotional intelligence charter
with her school in Harlem, New York,
and they want to feel as a team
supported and respected, peaceful,
interested in power and as did
appreciate it and motivated.
So she has no rules in her school, just
feelings. And then they say, all right,
well we've want to feel that way.
What do we need to do each day
in order to have those feelings?
What are the specific measurable,
Realistic Behaviors that we need to
do each day to create that emotional
climate? So it shows up in many ways.
This is another high school in New York.
They want to feel balanced and energized.
That's where I was just in Mexico.
They'd much more creative
with their charters,
their fifth grade classroom
here in San Francisco.
They wouldn't feel comfortable,
confident, creative focus, ecstatic,
respected and challenged.
List goes on.
The mood meter helps us
build more awareness.
So how do you build awareness of emotion?
Well,
you can learn the facial expressions,
the body language, the vocal tones,
the physiology and the behavior that
occur in each of these quadrants.
You can build that vocabulary.
There are 2000 words that we could plot
on the motivator we use to usually you
could learn how emotions influence
your judgments and the way your brain
operates.
So for example,
yellow is great for creative processing
where the green is great for building
consensus.
You can learn strategies to help you
manage the full range of emotions.
And you can see that schools adopt these
practices in really interesting ways
through art work and
other things like that.
These are working with the boys and girls
clubs across the United States now to
build this into our
after school programming,
we haven't built an app where you can
plot yourself on to your heart's delight.
So last two minutes. Can I ask, I want
to just take a moment to read this quote.
Okay.
How many of you feel like your fuse
is shorter than it's ever been?
I want to feel that way.
Like your stimulus to response is
getting tighter and tighter and tighter.
That's what we're finding
across the states.
So we built a tool to help with that,
and we say,
if you take our six step seriously,
now you can avoid the 12th steps later.
So you are triggered,
right?
Most people rely on breathing exercises
like that to help them deactivate.
But we've learned is that there's one
more piece you can throw in there.
We call it seeing your best self.
What we've learned is that our nation has,
this is a study of thousands of people.
They're begging to be more compassionate.
They're saying that their best self
is someone who is more compassionate.
So think about that. You're triggered
by someone at work or at home,
you go for the automatic response. But
if you pause and say, wait a minute,
my best self is someone who is more
compassionate. Do you think that my guide,
how you behave following
that just all dodger heads.
Cause that's what my research shows.
It will.
Then we have other ways we
have to manage conflict, right?
We have to realize that it's not
just about me, it's about we.
And we have to figure out like what
was the other person actually feeling.
You can't do that in the moment.
You actually need time to process that.
So let me wrap up by saying
just two last things.
First is we've done pretty
big experiments on this work,
randomized trials and 60 places.
And I found that in schools,
when you do this work,
you get better outcomes for students.
So you get better outcomes for
teachers and classroom climates.
You get less bullying
and all that great stuff.
Can I ask everybody to take one last
deep breath with me? Not of your life,
but just have this time together.
So to wrap up,
how many of you believe
that emotions matter? Cool.
How many of you think that the skills
of emotional intelligence are real?
How many of you've heard of the things
soft skills? That's how they think of it.
What I'm here to tell you is that
your brain is replete with emotion and
cognition. Our goal is to have those
two systems work well together.
Oftentimes,
one has more power than the other.
Our nation is one that
cares more cognition,
that emotion when they're
both living simultaneously.
So the question is how do we infuse
more emotion into the cognition?
Third,
never too early or too late
to develop these skills.
I promise you that never too early
or too late. There's no excuses.
I think fourth,
there are creative ways to develop an AI
face to face and using technology. Uh,
I've developed an APP for example,
is one way to show how technology can
support you and tracking your emotions and
learning over the course
of a week or a month. Wow,
I've been in the blue for this long.
What do I need to do to shift my
life a little bit? And finally,
what I'll just say as my little hope for,
um,
proselytizing moment is that,
there's so much resistance in our nation
right now to taking people's feeling
seriously. I'm want to go to schools
and I hear teachers say things like,
Zip that we're not friends anymore.
I'm like devastated by that.
To think that like that child is not
seen as someone who is a feeling creature
who needs to be respected
and supported and developed.
And then you go into the workplace and
you see people that are all stressed and
they're feeling frustrated,
anger.
And there's not a lot of emotional
intelligence really brought into the
workplace environment.
So my primary interest in life is to
figure out ways that we can infuse these
skills into the way leaders lead.
And all of us are in relationship.
And my hope is that by doing so, we
get great outcomes, like better health,
better relationships, more creativity, um,
and maybe people get to achieve
their dreams. Thank you so much.
[inaudible].